the twilight saga was a worldwide
phenomenon and without its very first
film the franchise wouldn't have reached
the success it did so what exactly made
the first movie so special today we're
giving you a behind-the-scenes look at
some of the most surprising and adorable
moments that happened on set even the
most hardcore twyhards will be
questioning everything they know about
the film glad you're here we need an
empire
she thinks we cheat i know you're cheap
it's time to talk about how they brought
this thunderous baseball scene to life
putting together a vampire baseball
scene wasn't easy for anyone the visual
effects team had to map out the entire
scene digitally so that they'd be able
to add any extra footage they needed
catherine hardwick said they originally
wanted a little bit of sunshine but soon
realized that would mean making the
cullen clan sparkle an effect that would
cost them big bucks that was as far as
the digital effects went this twilight
film was on a budget which meant using
as many practical effects as possible
the most impressive part of the scene is
how they got the vampires moving for the
cullens they were attached to ropes and
harnesses while running to help them
achieve a smoother glide but for
villains james laurent and victoria
their actors walked through the field on
a magical green carpet to make it seem
as if they were floating
you better hold on tight spider monkey
bella and edward's infamous treetop
scene took quite a few different shots
with plenty of rope stunt doubles and a
helicopter to get this shot it was made
possible but there was still some
tweaking that needed to be done like
moving trees and adding in cardboard
ones to make the forest look a little
more full however the best part of the
behind the scenes may just be how
adorable rob and kristen were with one
another
do you trust me
in theory
the cgi and visual effects in twilight
were very minimal but there was no way
to have our paths attack a deer like
edward without the help of some movie
magic this opening scene was completely
digital from the forest deer running and
edward snatching it up mid-jump it was
all done with computers check out the
breakdown of this scene across the frame
to tackle the deer and of course we
couldn't do that for real so we did that
in visual effects talk about a jigsaw
puzzle the car accident scene in the
parking lot of forks high was filmed in
multiple parts this was to make sure
they kept the cast and crew as safe as
possible rob and kristen filmed their
parts without the car even being there
the actual accident was filmed without
any actors nearby as for edward's
superhuman strength the car door was
made out of a soft metal panel with
plasticine backings that was easy to
mold the complexity of the scene led to
plenty of adorable moments between the
actors on set that day especially
kristin this adorable behind the scenes
moment shows off that props even large
ones don't always function properly
kristin couldn't get the door open to
the truck and ruined the entire take on
one hand the mishap allowed her to show
off her goofy side to us
hi i'm robert
and i'm kristen
rob and kristen didn't spend all their
time on set sometimes they would get
called in for behind scenes interviews
where things got hilarious for actors
these two really couldn't seem to
remember the lines for the interview
i keep thinking that is part of the
thing let's see oh this comes down to
something there's the seven all right it
made it all even more adorable their
chemistry off and on screen was
undeniable okay i'm sorry i can't look
at you when i do it alright
bella swan isn't the most coordinated
person we know that from the very moment
she steps in the gym on her first day of
school volleyball definitely isn't her
forte but it turns out it's also not
kristin's in these behind the scenes
clips you can see that the moment where
bella accidentally hits mike in the head
with the volleyball wasn't her it was a
crew member on set purposely aiming the
volleyball at actor michael welch
instead they needed someone with good
aim to replicate bella's bad aim how
ironic
you're good how meta was the moment
edward caught the apple and replicated
the twilight book cover well it may have
looked cool but robert pattinson would
probably tell you it was just annoying
to film the moment took 13 takes in
total they attached the apple to a
fishing line and on a crane so that
they'd be able to give off the effect of
edward bouncing the apple back up with
his foot and landing in his hands
perfectly it's a good thing rob and
kristen found the whole thing hilarious
between takes edible art
and
dude
the wolves don't exactly become a main
focus of the franchise until new moon
but catherine hardwick still wanted to
include them when talking about the
cullens and quillute's history the most
cost-friendly way to do this was to
bring in actual wolves instead of using
visual effects it ended up turning out
extremely authentic
beautiful
very visually dynamic
filming in a room full of mirrors a
filmmaker's nightmare the studio fight
between edward and james was extremely
difficult to execute because they had to
maneuver the cameras and crew into a
position where they wouldn't be seen it
was the first scene of the entire film
to be shot but that didn't stop the
actors from bonding while the fight was
coordinated part of what you see in the
film was actually rob and cam jagande
improvising
you're beautiful
the visual effects lead called adding
the vampire sparkle the biggest
challenge they faced while making the
film because they needed to make edward
look smooth at the same time they did
this by mapping out robert and adding
sparkles in during editing but robert
and kristen still needed to film the
actual scene where he reveals himself it
may look like a simple take of them
relaxing in the meadow but in reality
the two actors were under a very bright
light to mimic the sun that was blinding
you can see them struggling to keep
their eyes open and their giggles of
relief when they call cut
cut good good huh
the outdoor prom scene was a nightmare
to film not only was it at 2 am but it
was only 22 degrees outside and the cast
and crew were freezing especially
kristen who had to get through the take
in nothing but a little sweater the
temperature also caused slippery
conditions and a wipeout from rob that
kristen still regrets not being there to
witness rob fell no i didn't see rob
fall i wish i did a lot was taken into
consideration when it came to the
soundtrack of the film catherine had to
make sure that the music also played
into the emotional aspect of the story
and was there for the entire process
rob even has two original songs that
made it onto the soundtrack of the first
film the songs were titled never think
and let me sign and the song edward
walks into the cafeteria to was sung by
his sister
could you act human i mean i've got
neighbors from the start rob and kristen
hit it off so much that rob was warned
not to date kristen off screen because
she was underage however before that
catherine needed to test out their
chemistry in her bedroom the two acted
out the couple's first kiss at
catherine's house and it was rob's one
chance to impress looks like he did
he then went into major prep mode
working out five days a week and even
getting his driver's license but he ran
into some trouble creatively when
filming and was almost fired they flew
up and they're like yeah you gotta you
have to do the opposite of what you're
doing now you're gonna get fired today
luckily it all worked out both off and
on screen i am here to do my my big
cameo this is my break into the movie
industry it's a well-known fact that
stephanie meyer made an appearance at
the diner where bella and charlie have
dinner one night but have you ever
wondered what she was doing on her
laptop meyer was actually writing
breaking dawn while this scene was being
filmed she had to make sure that they
didn't catch anything that was on her
laptop in fear that fans would become
super sleuths and zoom in on her screen
it wasn't all vegetarian sparkly
vampires on set things got dark
especially for nikki reed rosalie's
platinum blonde hair posed a huge issue
and was quite the nightmare for the
actress my hair fell out it took 36
hours initially to make me blonde and
every other day i was bleaching my head
and my skin
yikes yeah let's just keep pretending
like this isn't dangerous for all of us
um hopefully i look as good as that he
was running quite fast there the
twilight saga new moon took us twihards
deep into the mythology of vampires
werewolves and everything in between but
behind the movie magic was a cast and
crew who worked impossibly hard to make
sure everything was perfect when it
reached the big screen from wolfpack
camp to groundbreaking special effects
let's dive into the behind the scenes of
new moon all right let's roll it
the first twilight film only skimmed the
surface when it came to stephanie
meyer's werewolf history
just like it was bella's new moon was
our first tango with the truth behind
the quillutes that means the cgi and
special effects department had some big
shoes to fill they used some advanced
computer technology to construct the
werewolves and used references from real
life timberwolves they were then able to
use these digitized models and add them
to the raw footage when it came to
filming they used plastic or cardboard
stand-in werewolves that kristen stewart
tried to avoid acting with at all times
it's like five seconds of me reacting
like
but for taylor filming as a wolf was
pretty exciting it allowed him to do
some of his own stunt wire work and i'm
glad to have the wolf the wolf pack here
now robert pattinson also got to get
involved with the stunt coordinators
during edward's confrontation with the
valtteri while the stunt doubles took on
most of the intense action our paths
still stepped in and did some wire work
as well overall the valtteri fight scene
was intricately choreographed to run
smoothly and took a lot of practice from
both the stunt doubles and the actors at
the end of the day rob was congratulated
with a cake because it was his birthday
[Applause]
sadly kristen stewart didn't get to
become an expert motorcycle rider while
filming new moon but she did get to have
some fun pretending to ride one to keep
kristen safe but also get as many
close-ups of her as possible they
secured bella's bike to a dolly platform
that carried the motorcycle while it
moved to give the appearance that
kristen was actually riding it
it was cool to be on the back of a
motorcycle on the back of a car
kristen had another opportunity to get
involved with some stunts but it was
just a little too risky bella's birthday
party at the cullens may just be the
most misleading scene of the entire film
the truth is that the majority of the
time the main cast weren't even the ones
filming even characters not involved in
the vampire violence like rosalie and
esme were replaced with stunt doubles
bella and jasper's stunt doubles both
wore wires so that they could be
controlled when pushed back by edward
the glass bella falls into was fake
breakaway material to prevent the stunt
double from getting hurt the real actors
were carefully brought in to film a bit
of the choreographed action a part that
jackson rathbone absolutely loved he put
so much effort into his attack that even
kristen admitted that she was terrified
by his performance
a little bit of action a little bit of
ducking and jiving
creating the werewolves is one thing but
showcasing jacob's werewolf powers in
human form like his strength took some
added effort in order to give the
audience and bella a hint of jacob's new
strengths he lifted his motorcycle out
of bella's truck while it isn't
far-fetched to think taylor could have
totally done it without help they
attached the bike to wires and a crane
to make the lift look effortless
dude when did you get so strong
speaking of effortlessness the cgi team
was able to make these behind the scenes
to big screen transitions look seamless
production on the saga changed from
portland to vancouver after the first
film which meant a lot of the buildings
we saw in the first film were miles and
miles away the set designers were able
to put together or find replicas of
bella's home and the cullen's home but
locations like forks high were
completely recreated with green screens
it's almost impossible to tell
the cliff diving sequence in new moon
was finally kristin's time to shine when
it came to trying out some stunts but
director chris weitz put some
expectations on kristen that just
weren't possible yeah i like stunt work
kind of scary though
to give the appearance as if she was
drowning he asked kristen to put weights
in her pockets to allow herself to sink
with his experience from harry potter
rob was making all the water work look
like a piece of cake so chris was a
little apprehensive as to why kristen
was finding it all a bit overwhelming
but when he decided to suit up and try
putting weights in his pockets as well
he realized that not only was kristin
right in being terrified but rob was
superhuman for not feeling the same i
decided to go down there in a wetsuit
waited down and i started to panic in
the end it all worked out and looked
amazing
something else that turned out amazing
in the film the entire italy sequence at
the end but it wasn't without a lot of
work from everyone involved
before even shooting the production team
went on a detailed tour of tuscany and
lombardi in order to find the perfect
location because they were looking to
keep a more renaissance vibe instead of
a classic gothic vampire approach they
were very very picky
the choice of montepulciano was a sort
of big discussion and we really worked
on that to get it right once they
settled on a location they were able to
use it as inspiration for creating the
inner workings of the valtteri layer in
the studio
the costume department also faced some
challenges in italy they had to find a
quick way to be able to put 700 extras
in cloaks for the valtteri scene when
they were originally asked for 350. it
started off as 350. then it grew to 400
and then someone asked me well how many
do you really think you can do that
meant finding something that we could
fit multiple body types
we came up with a simple formula almost
like one size fits all it may have taken
a lot of hard work but that italian sea
of red was incomparable on screen
taylor lautner's wardrobe also needed a
little extra attention from the costume
department in this film even if he was
shirtless for the majority of it in the
novel jacob is supposed to have
drastically changed from one moment to
the next although taylor did have a big
transformation they still had to make
his appearance more exaggerated we
tailored all of the t-shirts he wore to
make it seem like he was busting out of
them he also had lifts added to his
shoes so he would tower over bella
there wasn't much room for improv in the
twilight films because of the
franchise's complicated storyline but
anna kendrick was able to show off her
skills in this scene with bella outside
of the movie theater her speech about
zombies totally unscripted looks like
chris white saw her improv potential
even before she moved on to share her
talents with the pitch perfect team
like it's supposed to be a metaphor for
consumerism
it wasn't all wire tricks and near
drownings for this cast their chemistry
and hilarious personalities led to some
of these heartwarming bloopers on set
but like many film sets being a part of
the new moon cast did come with its own
set of rules for the second film
director chris weitz made sure that
every actor cast as part of the wolf
pack could prove they held first nation
status he wanted to ensure he was
representing the quillutes properly
production designer david brisbane even
met with the clilu executive council to
make sure they were being as accurate as
possible once those actors were cast
they were sent straight to what chris
termed wolf camp it's here they were
trained by professionals and were put on
strict diets that had to follow chaske
spencer who played sam found the whole
experience pretty rewarding so what they
did is he threw us into circuit training
and muscle confusion workouts and then
we just eat all day it's pretty much
four to six meals a day plus three to
four protein shakes a day as well we are
shooting scene 106 and i knew that from
memory
the twilight saga eclipse needed to be
epic between its vampire battles and
emotional love triangle david slade had
to create the ultimate third part of the
twilight franchise it's such a different
experience in this behind-the-scenes
look at the movie you'll see that the
cast and crew's love for stephanie
meyer's story and a whole lot of hard
work is what made it possible ready to
see some groundbreaking cgi and what
taylor lautner was really like off
camera
don't hold back
not in my nature
while the characters grew and changed
throughout the twilight saga there was
one thing that stayed consistent vampire
speed one of the biggest challenges of
the movie has always been to capture
vampire speed getting human actors to
move at an inhuman pace not the easiest
the film crew had to come up with some
unique creations like the magic carpet
that they used during eclipse it was
basically a large treadmill that they'd
have the actors run on while speeding by
with the camera on another truck as long
as you're not seeing their feet it feels
like they're actually going very fast
they'd also have another version of the
carpet that they'd use in the studio for
scenes that required green screen the
cast got a little competitive with it
and even challenged one another on who
could run on the carpet's fastest level
i beat everyone well the magic carpet
was kind of magic there were just some
vampire shots that couldn't be done
without the help of computers like this
victoria moment that required them to
construct the entire scene digitally
after filming with her stunt double in
the studio where they had to create
custom green screen platforms to imitate
the jumping
she's closed the vampire speed wasn't
the only road bump they had to overcome
filming on vancouver mountains wasn't
ideal for the cast and crew of eclipse
because the fall weather didn't offer
them the snow they needed and fake snow
was out of the question in public areas
instead the set director got creative we
built the entire mountaintop on the
stage and dressed it with the snow that
we would need for the sequence it took a
crew of about 50 people to go through
these vigorous steps to bring stephanie
meyer and director david slade's vision
to life the set was surrounded by green
screen and gave them the freedom to film
the bone chilling final battle with
victoria and jacob and edward's
emotional heart to heart in the tent if
she chooses me would you try to kill me
that's an intriguing idea
in the end it was the right choice not
only visually but because they were able
to spend as much time as they needed in
the studio whereas on location they
would have been constrained by time and
we could spend three weeks shooting the
final conflict which required extensive
amount of stunt work and wire work the
werewolves in eclipse may have looked
epic on screen but behind the scenes not
so much they used plastic wolves
werewolf-shaped punching bags for the
fight scenes and taylor lautner even
stepped in as a stand-in for the more
emotional scenes oh there's taylor
swift
how are you doing
but the hard work was actually adding
the werewolves in during post-production
we pushed a lot of our technology
further than we've ever pushed it on
eclipse they added more detail to the
wolves in their fur and even their
muscles than they had in the previous
films when it came to filming each
location needed to be scanned and
created as a digital 3d model to
integrate the wolves in their scenes
seamlessly i'll strategically shoot
points on this hill right here and i'll
use those points so that we can build a
3d model of it later so that our wolves
have something to stand on they came a
long way from using real wolves in the
first film i've decided to throw a party
at your place i've never seen your house
no one's ever seen their house
moving filming locations from portland
to vancouver after the first twilight
film got even more complicated in
eclipse when the crew realized that
they'd be needing the cullen house a
whole lot more naturally they came up
with a solution we knew that we couldn't
consolidate everything into one room and
cheetah like we did a new moon so we
made the decision to build the structure
yep they built the entire interior and
exterior cullen house that we see on
screen during eclipse right down to the
forest surrounding it they filled the
exterior of the house with fake trees
rocks and realistic canvases my name's
xavier i play riley in eclipse david
slade knew that telling riley's story
properly was important to tie the film
all together but with the books being
from bella's point of view they didn't
have much information on riley and had
to bring in the expert stephanie meyer
there was a lot of confusion as to what
was going on off screen and i had some
stuff written up for riley so we went
through that once his story was
established they set off to their
locations with a lot of rain machines
xavier was a trooper and shot in a
wetsuit for hours to keep warm while
doing a lot of the wire work himself
oh the wolf coming up run
we all know while watching a movie that
everything is not what it seems but
knowing and actually seeing the
behind-the-scenes footage is a whole
different story during the scene where
jacob carries bella through the forest
took a lot of prep work i literally went
and got my rear end molded to make this
day easier on taylor but their plans
involving a super innovative rig and
molded seat didn't go as planned the
idea was for taylor to just support
kristin's weight while walking with her
in the rig but they just couldn't get it
to look realistic on camera or like
taylor can you just carry kristen for
the day so poor taylor spent hours
walking back and forth carrying kristen
while it was a piece of cake for him in
the beginning by the end of the day he
was completely broken by the end of the
day my arms are just like shaking so bad
speaking of onset workouts the cullens
actors went through some intense
training for their roles as vampires
they put like a piece of cheese up there
and then we all run
try to get the cheese
before filming even began they attended
group workout sessions to get in shape
and develop their fighting techniques
welcome to our vampire bat cave this is
where all the booty kicking goes down it
was important to david that the cullens
each had their own style of fighting
that represented their background while
also taking into consideration the moves
jasper would be showing them from his
war days one more thing
never turn your back on your enemy for
example alice is more agile and light on
her feet while emmett is all about his
size and strength believe it or not the
actors performed a lot of their own
stunts adding to the realism of it all
would you do me the extraordinary honor
of marrying me
the eclipse team had the tough task of
bringing to life bella's engagement ring
it took them four different attempts and
in the end they only achieved the level
of perfection they needed by asking for
help from stephanie what we ended up
doing is having a conversation with
stephanie meyer who then drew us a
little sketch of the ring that they
ended up finally building the ring is 14
karat white gold and kristen ended up
being the lucky one who got to take the
ring home as a memento of her time on
set
i'm gonna need that ring
we can't talk about bella and edward's
engagement without discussing their
meadow and how it came to be david
recognized that this was one of the most
important locations in bedward's story
and needed to make everything perfect
this meant creating an idealistic place
that was cinematically beautiful it's
the only piece of sanctuary that edward
and bella have to bring his vision to
life they hand planted thousands of
flowers and mixed with kristen and
edward's chemistry the scene was
breathtaking we have established
dynamics that nobody can mess with
before bringing these beautiful scenes
like the meadow to life they had to deal
with one small tiny matter kristen's
hair kristin had cut her hair for her
role in the film the runaways the
twilight filmmakers were completely
against the notion and even offered
kristen what she called many ridiculous
things to not cut her hair but she had
confidence in the wig department
confidence that may have been misplaced
i just thought we'd have a better wig
and uh it's okay her wig in eclipse
wasn't the greatest and caused a lot of
issues in the editing room that resulted
in reshoots there were even reports that
because of the wig kristen was involved
in some heated talks while filming the
tent scene and stephanie meyer herself
even confirmed the wig troubles and it's
something that they've had to deal with
they were able to fix the wig but fans
still had their issues with it when the
film was released
we're throwing grapes into taylor's
mouth the cast and crew weren't always
dealing with an issue or two some days
on set were just about having some fun
or for taylor good old healthy
competition when he was bored in between
takes he would gather his own tiny film
crew with an assistant and create
challenges for himself involving grapes
and footballs he may just be the
greatest grape catcher hollywood has
ever seen were you watching that
what would a movie set be without some
great outtakes including these hilarious
bloopers
with a cast that was spending every day
for months with one another we can only
just imagine how many funny moments took
place on camera and off where could she
be
oh there she is
according to kristen there were a lot of
these moments especially between her and
robert pattinson me and rob laugh more
in the really serious scenes and like
much much less in the scenes it's
supposed to be light and funny they just
couldn't keep it together and ruined
multiple takes while working with one
another it's ironic to think about how
robb went from almost being fired on the
first twilight film because of his
seriousness to him not being able to
stop laughing while filming eclipse i
came back off i came back after lunch
was like hi i want to keep my job
one thing is for sure robsten's
chemistry was undeniable ramping up to
do that scene for like three years
filming got off to a rocky start the
crew got stranded on an island and
robert pattinson crashed a boat could
have been better the fourth film in the
twilight franchise required a lot of
work and some tight security to make
sure the production went off without a
hitch kristen stewart even had to cover
her wedding dress with a cape whenever
she wasn't filming it's a good disguise
which producer makes a sneaky appearance
in the movie
filming in brazil brought the cast and
crew of breaking dawn part one a fair
amount of troubles
particularly when it came to filming on
an island the team was just three days
into filming on location in south
america when they wound up being
stranded on a small island overnight
because of extremely bad weather the
crew acted quickly and tarps were
brought out to protect the cast from
getting too wet and the set pieces from
becoming damaged since filming abroad
proved to be tricky especially with
having only one week in brazil the
majority of the set was recreated in
louisiana to fill most of the indoor
honeymoon shots with cgi added after the
fact
bella and edward's wedding was a pretty
big deal
and it was saved to be the last scene
filmed with major security precautions
taken
there were literally helicopters
overhead making sure no one could see
what was going on except for those
involved with the production on the
ground blankets and umbrellas were used
to keep the set and cast out of sight
christian stewart was even sporting a
cape when the cameras stopped rolling to
avoid any leaked images of the
custom-made wedding dress just to make
sure everything was extra secure there
were also literal police officers
surrounding the scene
running at incredible speed for the
camera wasn't just a result of training
elizabeth reeser and kellen lutz were
actually set in a pretty precarious rig
with a rolling treadmill the actors were
secured on the rig by this green beam
while it was also being pulled by a
truck with cameras hooked up to it
capturing all the action
filming in a gorgeous country like
brazil might seem like a dream but for
robert pattinson one scary shooting day
was a real life nightmare the actor was
manning a boat in the water but instead
of smooth sailing pattinson wound up
crashing the rig
to make it all worse it wasn't a private
affair the edward cullen actor had five
thousand pairs of eyes watching on the
upside the actor was already pretty used
to crashing the boat since he had
regularly done so when he was taking
boating lessons evidently it seems like
he could have used a few more lessons
kristen stewart and robert pattinson had
to get very intimate for the cameras on
numerous occasions
but what they hadn't planned for was
needing to reshoot their climactic
intimate scene initially the footage
captured was way too risque and required
the film to have an r rating but with so
many fans of the franchise being younger
the team opted to go to camera again the
major issue
too much of pattinson's rear end was
featured also you used to be able to see
my butt in it while it was a tough scene
for kristen stewart to do she was happy
with it in the end even though it was
just 40 seconds long in the final cut
watching bella give birth and breaking
dawn part 1 is still a traumatizing
experience and unfortunately it wasn't
much better on set for the cast and crew
pattinson even called it perhaps the
ickiest birth scene ever filmed it's not
a fun one to watch with all the gory
details and bella's clearly intense pain
with her already being in such a tough
state sickly and severely underweight
the scene is far from pleasant
the birth scene may be disturbing but
credit has to be given to the team for
how creative they got when it came to
bringing the moment to life the creepy
blood on newborn renesme was actually a
combination of strawberry jam and cream
cheese we can only imagine it would have
been a very sticky situation for
everyone involved
three hours worth of makeup and
prosthetics were applied to christian
stewart for her birthing scene
surprisingly much of what we see of
stewart's body is actually prosthetics
pretty much from the shoulders down
the large table she was laying on had a
space in it so the actress could lay her
body down underneath the prosthetics she
wasn't alone under the table though a
puppeteer was based inside to maneuver
the limbs realistically
kellen lutz put his down time to
extremely productive use while shooting
the final two twilight films
between takes the actor went workout
crazy and was getting fit consistently
for the full seven months of filming
resulting in a very buff body lutz made
very good use of all that downtime
while taylor lautner was famously
topless throughout the majority of the
twilight saga
doesn't he own a shirt robert pattinson
had his fair share of shirtless moments
especially when edward and bella filmed
some of their spiciest and most intimate
scenes in breaking dawn part one the
actor spent a full six months doing
intense training and watching his diet
before filming
because it's the only one i really
worked out for all of which ended once
the intimate scene had finished filming
so many of the male actors in twilight
seemed to be on intense workout and diet
regimens and lautner was of course no
exception all those shirtless scenes
required a lot of work behind the scenes
but for the actor the biggest challenge
was actually the amount of calories he
had to eat during his intense workout
times lautner was often sneaking bits of
food between takes to contribute to the
whopping 4 000 calories he had to eat
per day
pattinson really put a lot of effort and
work into his role as edward in fact he
learned to speak portuguese
just for the sake of shooting the scene
with the housekeepers when edward and
bella are on their honeymoon in brazil
he may be needing some more lessons
though
renesmee as a newborn shockingly wasn't
just a prop doll
there was a real infant on set depending
on what was being filmed the team
swapped the doll for the real child and
both had cgi retouching done and editing
performing with an infant is an intense
experience
working with a real baby isn't always
easy though especially when it's not
happy and screams to let everyone know
it
jacob's emotions in breaking down part
one go to a whole new level taylor
lautner really gave it his all when it
came to the twilight films so no doubt
he was invested in the final products
according to kristin stewart the jacob
actor actually cried while watching one
of the cuts with the cast with all the
work time and effort it's no surprise
lautner caught some feelings
it was it was tough when it came to an
end
the writer of the twilight books was
never too far being on set for all of
the filming and she actually made the
cut in a major scene amid the crowd
watching edward and bella getting
married is the author stephanie meyer
she the other screenwriter melissa
rosenberg and rick godfrey a producer
got to attend the wedding together
since meyer was one of the screenwriters
an executive producer and the creator of
the whole twilight universe she
definitely earned her cameo appearance
it had been a while since her first as a
restaurant customer in the first
twilight film and we all thought it was
the best idea we'd ever heard that was
genius who knew vampires were such good
dancers the epic conclusion to the
twilight saga had plenty of memorable
moments that fans loved the behind the
scenes of this film was chock full with
even more moments that will give you a
whole new perspective on your favorite
characters it's good to get physical
when i've always literally stood behind
people and been like from the hard work
put in to create your favorite moments
to bloopers and pranks between the cast
and crew these are the behind the scenes
moments that will make you love twilight
even more
she's amazing right
[Music]
during the final battle with the voltori
rennes may is sitting on jacob's wolf
form while the wolves have been
completely computer generated throughout
the series in this case actress
mackenzie foy is sitting on an
animatronic rig that was designed to
look like the midsection of the wolf
they actually used two different
versions of the rake for filming one
version was operated manually by a crew
member just off screen with the motion
being used to assist the final animation
we see the other rig was motion
controlled which they programmed to move
according to animation they had already
done that was new for us that was pretty
fun
i was born to be a vampire
director bill condon knew that bella
needed to have a unique vampire look
that differentiated her from her mortal
look a big part of the new look had to
do with bella's costume and how she was
much more confident and powerful now her
new look included leather a black color
scheme and more form-fitting clothing it
also included colored contact lenses so
irritate your eyes at first
which stewart hated this is one thing i
can't wait to say goodbye to even though
it wasn't the most comfortable
experience for stewart we think her
vampire look is awesome and showed off a
whole new badass side to her character
bella she's got your eyes bella if you
thought the cgi baby was creepy wait
till you see what they originally used
they had an animatronic doll that was
puppeteered off camera and it looked
creepy so creepy that it was nicknamed
chuck esme after the evil killer doll
rick godfrey the creator of the doll
hated it as well is one of the most
grotesque animatronic babies you know
ever to not be seen on film knowing this
we're glad they went with the weird cgi
baby instead
he would just turn into this completely
different person after deciding the
animatronic baby was nightmare fuel they
brought in real babies to fill the part
robert pattinson absolutely adored all
the babies they had on set he would just
turn into this completely different
person whenever they would take a baby
away from him he would complain and
argue why they have to keep taking them
pattinson had a great time acting with
the babies and children and it shows in
his performance
telling war stories
we're just standing there like freaking
statues
the epic final battle scene showcases
the wolf pack attacking the voltori in
an awesome badass sequence the behind
the scenes however not as epic since the
wolves were completely animated the
animators needed reference to work with
so on set they had crew members hold
giant cardboard cutouts of wolves
feigning the action of the battle they
called the cardboard cutouts the wolf
standees and used them for multiple
moments during the battle this includes
the cardboard wolves pretending to
attack the volturi and the epic shot of
all the wolves running towards the fight
which looks a bit more silly with their
cardboard stand-ins it's hard to watch
the scene the same way after seeing this
the main thing is not to move too fast
turning into a vampire comes with a lot
of new abilities most of which require
stunt work stewart loved to do her own
stunts and would get upset whenever she
couldn't she's like pissed off when a
double has to do anything that being
said some of the stunt work was a little
too much for her she was clearly filled
with nervous excitement while doing some
of her stunts laughing after each take
jesus christ i don't know why i can't
handle that i can't handle it
pattinson also did a lot of his own
stunt work including some pretty intense
wire work that was pretty fun however he
had trouble doing one stunt in
particular a simple somersault he failed
on multiple takes while his co-star
kristen stewart nailed it every time
pattinson had the whole crew laughing at
his inability to complete a simple stunt
he went to his stunt double for help who
can be seen putting his head in his
hands after a failed attempt by
pattinson
very proud to have her be playing my
daughter
mackenzie foy was one of the last
additions to the main cast coming on to
play renesmee all the other cast members
made her feel welcome and would play
games with her on set she played
football with taylor a game where
someone tries to catch her hands and
would have staring contest with everyone
the cast only had nice things to say
about her praising her for her hard work
mackenzie's great she's very
self-possessed for a very really young
girl
come time for reshoots robert pattinson
was ready in all aspects except one his
hair he had cut it before reshoots began
meaning it wasn't the right style for
edward he ended up wearing a wig which
he hated he branded it frankenstein's
monster we still think he looks great
the final battle begins with the cullens
and wolves running at the voltori they
filmed this scene on a large soundstage
with a green screen backdrop the actors
actually ran at full speed while the
cameras followed them they had to film
this scene multiple times which meant
running
running and more running we can only
imagine how tired the actors were after
recording this scene
what makes the final battle scene so
shocking is that it isn't in the book
the original ending in the book was
deemed too boring so stephanie meyer and
writer melissa rosenberg came up with
the idea of the giant ending battle the
way i approached it was who would be the
most shocking to kill and because
they're all there for carlisle it made
sense he was the one rosenberg was at
the premiere of the movie and watched as
the audience screamed and yelled during
the scene director bill condon addressed
the risk it was taking the worst thing
would be if people felt pissed off we
would say the risk paid off
you're in it you just gotta join in
during filming for the final battle all
the actors who were on the cullen side
orchestrated a dance-off prank they
choreographed an entire dance and got
the audio and camera crews in on it as
well when action was called the audio
crew played a song and the cullens all
lined up to perform their dance moves
the voltori actors and director bill
condon had no idea what was going on
this prank was actually included as a
post-credit surprise when the film was
released in theaters you know whatever
they'll let me do i'll do ashley green
who played alice was more than up to the
task of doing her own stunts she has a
martial arts background and was
routinely practicing for her stunt work
if i know there's a stunt sequence i'm
you know in the gym training by myself
to make sure i'm kind of up to the task
and working with stun trainer she
performed some wire work including doing
a stunt in a harness she could twist in
the final shot looks amazing and shows
that green's hard work paid off
vampires have superhuman strength and
regularly show it off the behind the
scenes however makes their strength a
little less impressive emmett actor
kellen lutz can be seen carrying a giant
prop rock placing it down without any
effort this prop was a breakaway which
stew and lutz can be seen breaking with
ease it's not the first time lutz has
handled such props in a
behind-the-scenes photo from breaking
dawn part 1 he and his co-star nikki
reed can be seen casually carrying giant
tree props
stewart's last day on set was anything
but glamorous while running barefoot
through a fake forest stewart stepped on
something not too pleasant the very last
thing i did was step on a rusty nail
ouch that's a rough last day but stewart
took it in stride claiming it was
exactly what she wanted it was literally
perfect we wouldn't expect anything less
from the twilight veteran at this point
we're not sure what we love more the
epic final battle between our heroes and
the voltori or all the behind the scene
shenanigans that took place while
filming it the epic conclusion to the
twilight saga was under a lot of
pressure to deliver a satisfying finale
which we think it did a great job in
doing director bill condon worked well
with his actors and was passionate about
making this film special it's nice to
know that everyone got along and had fun
while creating this film and it helps us
appreciate it even more what was your
favorite behind the scenes moment